Putin just pushed the world a lot closer  to World War III four regions of eastern  Ukraine are apparently now joining  Russia forever these regions held a vote  ran by Russian pit government officials  who went door-to-door with guns and  armed guards to make sure everyone got  their votes in completely legitimate and  none of these regions are officially  Russian any attack on them would be an  act of War so Vlad has made it clear  that he will use nukes if anyone tries  to reclaim those territories on top of  lap 2 more Adventures happen that are  really pushing us to World War III  subscribe for part two to learn what  they are